salimos de Sudán en busca de seguridad
en Marruecos hay cerca de 2000
demandantes de asilo que huyen de la
guerra de Sudán la mayoría han llegado
en los últimos dos años el país magrebí
no les ofrece refugio y bloquea su
avance hacia Europa son jóvenes que
buscan un lugar seguro donde se
reconozca su derecho al asilo para
empezar una nueva vida
si FES su danés Yuyu de la guerra en su
país hacia Marruecos donde lleva más de
un año bloqueado porque cada vez que
intenta cruzar la frontera la policía
marroquí se lo impide su intención es
conseguir asilo en Europa
lo he intentado nueve veces Cada vez me
detienen a la fuerza me golpean son
racistas conmigo le quitan el suéter los
zapatos no me dejan nada hasta el móvil
me han robado en dos ocasiones las
fronteras europeas cada vez son más
infranqueables para personas como shift
se siente desorientado y agotado por
este bloqueo que no le permite alcanzar
sus derechos
la Unión Europea es la traidora si la
Unión Europea quisiera tomar la decisión
de dejar entrar a los refugiados podrían
abrir la frontera en un segundo que no
nos dificulten cada vez el camino que
nos dejen llegar de uno en uno dicen que
Marruecos es un lugar seguro esto es un
estado seguro nosotros no hemos
encontrado ninguna seguridad en
Marruecos
es un superviviente de la masacre que
tuvo lugar en la frontera del enclave
español de melilla el 24 de junio de
2022 ese día murieron al menos 23
personas cuando la policía quiso abortar
un intento de salto de la valla que
separa Marruecos de España Marruecos se
recibe cantidades millonarias para
impedir a las personas migrantes y
refugiadas llegar a suelo europeo solo
España en los últimos cinco años ha
pagado más de 120 millones de euros a su
país vecino según las partidas públicas
del Ministerio del interior además la
Unión Europea prevé inyectar más de 500
millones de euros a Marruecos hasta el
2027 esta externalización de fronteras
produce muerte y violencia
Este soy yo y este es mi amigo esta fue
la última vez que le vi y ahora está
desaparecido no sé dónde está pienso que
si yo no hubiera conseguido huir podría
también estar desaparecido ahora estoy
así sin más no puedo volver atrás y no
puedo seguir adelante estoy así y ya
está
me rompieron y ahora soy discapacitado
no puedo hacer nada y estoy buscando mi
futuro
un año después de la masacre daú todavía
se recupera de los golpes malvive en
esta escuela abandonada Marruecos no le
ofrece Refugio ni asistencia ha pedido
ayuda al alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
Aunque sin éxito
solo pedimos al alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
que vea las condiciones en las que
vivimos
Es peligroso podemos enfermar creo que
ni los animales podrían vivir aquí
el alto comisionado de las Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados es el único
organismo con capacidad para registrar
peticiones de asilo en Marruecos el
estado no facilita el proceso muchos de
los udaneses que llegan a esta oficina
ya han intentado pedir asilo en otros
países de tránsito pero sin lograrlo
Marruecos es el último país que les
queda antes de llegar a Europa el
representante de la organización admite
la falta de soluciones
el objetivo principal es que seamos
claros en lo que hacemos y en lo que
podemos aportar
esa frustración que han evocado y que
nuestro equipo atiende cada día
va en función de los recursos que
tenemos es muy duro
es como un servicio de urgencias de un
hospital que no puede atender a todo el
mundo es duro pero nuestro equipo hace
un trabajo remarcable y muy difícil y
Qué difícil
nosotros no venimos de un estado seguro
y vamos hacia otro estado seguro no
somos vecinos de la guerra y en
Marruecos nos tratan con violencia no
somos criminales solo somos migrantes
exigimos que nos trasladen en un estado
seguro el que sea
Hazme de sus compañeros protestan contra
el racismo y la represión actualmente
hay unos 300 udaneses encarcelados en
Marruecos a la mayoría los condenaron
después de la masacre de melilla por los
delitos de favorecer la inmigración
clandestina ultraja las autoridades
entre otros cargos Desde esa tragedia
hay más de 80 desaparecidos el hermano
de hassan es uno de ellos solo conserva
sus fotos en Facebook y aún mantiene la
esperanza de localizarlo
mi hermano estuvo a melilla el día que
ocurrió aquello desde ese día que se
perdieron tantas personas Yo tengo dos
desaparecidos
no sé dónde están si en la cárcel
perdidos o muertos estamos sin ninguna
información
a un año de la masacre de melilla los
supervivientes y sus familias siguen
esperando verdad y Justicia el régimen
de fronteras de la Unión Europea ha
convertido Marruecos en una cárcel a
cielo abierto para estos jóvenes
mientras ven como la guerra se recrudece
en Sudán siguen bloqueados a la espera
de alcanzar la frontera Que los separa
de sus derechos